good afternoon my name is Regan
I am a Kiwi so please don't hold that
against me I'm also from Microsoft and I
am part of the commercial software
engineering team and one of the things
that we've encountered quite a lot
lately is with the say you know
everybody's really excited about
containers and what containers can do
and DevOps and we're finding a lot of
people are really keen to give this a
try and see what they can do with their
Windows systems and especially some of
their legacy apps so that's that's what
I'm here to talk to you today about it's
about moving some legacy apps that you
might have on a PI server and the back
of your server room and hopefully moving
it forward to a container so that you
can take advantage of some of the modern
infrastructure modern orchestration
systems get it into a CIC D pipeline and
maybe just make it a little bit more
easy to manage as well as being a Kiwi I
also have to apologize I don't have any
fancy gifts or animations or music I'm
not going to sing or anything else so
forgive me if you want to leave bits
cook so when we when we start would turn
the thing on that helps when we're
looking at applications and legacy
applications one of the things that we
want to think about is you know why why
should we modernize it what are the
benefits that we might get out of it and
so there's a certain you know people
might have a legacy app stuck on an i/o
server back of a room somewhere might be
happy doing its thing you know it might
be happy doing its thing for another 20
years as it has for the previous 20
years so maybe maybe you don't need to
move it but there are some benefits that
you can get out of you know moving these
applications potentially containerized
in them and some of those things but you
can see behind me you know if you have
this on a server that's pretty low
efficiency because you've got one
application generally per piece of ten
if you've got on a VM then you've got
either one application per VM on a
machine somewhere which you know is
taking up a lot of resources or maybe
you have lots of applications on this
one VM and if you're going tweak a knob
on one of them all the elements fall
over and break
so you know one of the problems that you
have with with traditional applications
as inefficient and inefficient sizes
messing around with the applications can
break stuff and then if it has been
sitting there for ages nobody
necessarily knows how to redeploy it and
if something goes wrong and you need to
stand it up again then you've probably
got a problem so there's a few benefits
I mean you can read off the slide there
but you know increased density is
something that you can get of containers
you know if you've got 20 hosts now
maybe you can drop that down to a couple
and load a whole lot of applications
here you know you can split applications
up change one application without
breaking all the others and redeploy it
as much as you like quite often and yeah
you can then change versions of parts of
applications without affecting other
ones and build that see ICD pipeline so
you can press a button and a new one
builds so if a server dies you can you
know push button and replace so why
containers one of the things worth with
with traditional machines is you know
hardware put everything on there you've
got CPUs you got RAM got heard us that
are assigned to your application your OS
we moved on from that we went to virtual
machines where we virtualized that OS
which is great so you could then move a
virtual machine from one machine to
another and it would still pretty much
run but you're still duplicating the OS
you were duplicating the storage you're
duplicating the memory for each virtual
machine that you created up so one of
the things that containers do is instead
of duplicating the OS instead of
duplicating all the RAM that's taken to
run that OS and all the storage that
holds that OS containers can basically
share the underlying OS and then the the
consumption layer is really what your
application consumes on top of the OS so
if you have a in fact I think over a
slight here we go that looks a little
bit like this so if you've got a
traditional VM running you've got an
application on it you know it's it's
hosting an OS it's hoping all its
applications it's using a set of memory
if you can imagine maybe each of those
is taking up 20 gigs of ram for example
12 gigs of ram maybe the
on each one and eight gigs around maybe
the application on each one if you could
take those two applications containerize
them and put them on the one host then
now you only have the twelve gig OS once
and the two eight gig applications once
each and basically save yourself
twelve gigs ram and a whole lot of disk
space as well so I think the animation
here shows you taking the the two
virtual machines splitting up the
applications rolling around in
individual containers and putting them
on a single host higher density saving a
lot of a lot of time and effort so
overall containers you know they give
you a lot of benefits if you're a
developer you want to change your
application and then you can iterate
fast on it you can change the code spin
it up test it change it again you know
if you are adding features to your
application you want to give them out to
your customers then you know three
through CI a CD pipelines builds all the
rest of that once you've committed your
changes it can go through tests
automatically and then it can
automatically deploy out to your
production systems for containers once
they have built and deployed they are
immutable so you don't have to go and
change them or you can't really go and
change them and if they die you can just
spin up another one and it can take its
place
so it's a nice sort of paradigm from the
dev point of view so for developers is
there's some some great features there
for IT you know cost savings on getting
that efficiency getting that density in
there there's a lot less effort
generally for IT for redeploying
something over and over again because it
tends to be scripted and built in in a
continuous manner and then you know if
your application suddenly needs to scale
with containers it's actually really
easy to scale it out so that you got you
know 10 containers running instead of
one container or two containers the
other thing that's really good about
containers and things that devs
specifically love about them is the
works on my machine and when you have a
container it works on your machine
basically you're taking that container
every every part of your application is
contained in it you can move that to
another place where containers run and
generally it will work on that machine
as well and another one and if you have
a look at you know Microsoft Azure for
example we've got a lot of places where
you can run containers including our
first party Azure community service and
then if you're looking at other clouds
there are also your first parties
offerings over there AWS and Google both
have kubernetes services that you can
run your containers on as well and you
can you know get offerings from some of
our partners Red Hat roll it out and
then you know host your containers on
those offerings as well so this whole
idea of building your application in a
container you know throwing it out
somewhere to run makes it much easier
than you know having to tweak around and
store files and turn knobs to make sure
it runs each time so Windows Server
containers and who has used containers
before the people Linux containers
windows containers not so many
okay so Linux containers have been
around for a while they're very popular
they're becoming more and more popular
every day you know the they've had quite
a long history with docker and Linux
windows containers are a little bit
newer than that
but that's it there are a couple of
years old good couple of years old now
so Windows containers come in a couple
of versions we have a Windows server
core version and we have a Windows nano
server version if you're going to build
a container for Windows your starting
point is pretty much Windows Server 2016
so your your first thing you do is need
to get your app to run on Windows Server
2016 the next point is you're going to
have to choose where it's going to be on
a Windows server core container or a
Windows Server nano container with
Windows Server coy you can pretty much
you know run all of your dotnet stacks
you can run 32-bit you can run 64-bit
applications most of the roles and
things on Windows Server will work on
there and so they're pretty versatile
nano server is a much more compact
version of Windows Server container it
will only run 64-bit and but it does
have good support
for.net core and some of the roles on
windows server including Laius so we've
got Windows Server containers we've got
some legacy applications you know how do
we get from there to - you know - here
sort of thing one of the things that we
need to think about before we actually
start migrating our application is well
should we as the is the first question
and then you know it should we migrate
it should we rewrite it
should we redeploy it or should we just
maintain our applications and so
migrating you know moving your
application to Windows containers taking
what you currently have working and
deploying it inside a Windows Server
container basically the same as it is
right now that's the first option
rewrite you could rewrite your
application in a you know if it's a
dotnet 1.1 application for example maybe
you can go and rewrite it to the latest
version of dotnet and then run it in a
Windows Server container running the
full dotnet or run it and dotnet core
and run it on a lighter container with a
dot near core runtime you've also
potentially got the option to redeploy
your application so if it's running an I
is maybe you could actually look at
redeploying it to a PEZ service so push
it to as your web apps for example so
that's that's always we're thinking
about as well you don't have to go down
the container path if you want to
modernize an old application and then
the last one there maintain it you know
maybe there is no value and actually
trying to containerize this thing maybe
it's too hard maybe these things it just
won't work
maybe there's no value to the business
and actually moving it so just
maintaining as a VM may still be a good
outcome for a legacy application so
definitely something you could you
should consider and if you are writing a
dotnet application and don't need
framework application one thing that you
should really look at these days also is
whether you would write that and donate
core and that really opens up the
ability for you to look at running it on
Windows or running it on Linux and that
just widens your choice of where you can
run your application you know whether
it's on differ
orchestrators whether it's on really
small IOT edge devices or whether it's
on windows servers so if you do look at
dotnet core um it's going to give you a
lot more opportunities if you're
rewriting an apt as to where you can run
it in the future and you know dotnet
core has really broad support Microsoft
builds images based on based on alpine
linux based on bionic just rose for
Windows server core and for no silver
nano there are multiple images there if
you can really squint you can see some
of them but there are images which
contain the SDK so if you need to fire
up a container to build your application
you can fire that in the SDK image then
you can take the build output of that
and you can publish it into a run time
container which is a lot smaller and
then publish your container just as a
runtime image and yeah that's that's
across all of the stacks here and one
thing you might notice if you're looking
at this if you've got really good
eyesight but we've got a bionic runtime
at the top there which is so it's not
that good it's 82 megabytes
the the Nano server image that other
than the list here is was an emissivity
of mix this one down here so it's about
two hundred Meg's so you can see them if
you're running a dotnet core application
on Linux you could be looking at an
image of around 80 mix on nano server
about 200 Meg's and I don't have one in
this list here but if you were going to
run that application on Windows server
core and then probably about five
gigabytes so there's there's a little
bit of a difference in the size of those
images and it's important because if you
are orchestrating and scaling in an
application if you wanted to take a
container and run it a thousand times
and the difference between running an 80
Meg container a thousand times and a
five gig container a thousand times as
it's a little quite a lot so this is a
an example of a legacy application here
this is one that I worked on in the 90s
early 90s so in product
in a few places and it was one that I
did some work with a customer to
containerized parts of it and what we
have in this application here is we have
sequel server as most applications did
we have a middle tier server in this
case which was a is plus comm layer we
had a web server and web clients would
hit the web server the web server would
talk to the middle tier middle tier
would do all of the talking to the
sequel server database and so on and
then we also had some internal clients
who would connect to the database
directly using a fat clone scenario and
one of the things about this being a
Windows environment was that all of us
was all done using Windows passed
through authentication and this middle
tier talking back was also Windows
passed through syndication but the web
server was was not that was a different
authentication scheme so when we look at
that application and we sort of think
you know what are we going to put into
containers there's an active directory
up there a solid and pointed out but
yeah so Active Directory pretty much no
you're not going to put Active Directory
into a container that just won't work
and you probably wouldn't to try anyway
sequel server yes it is possible to put
a sequel server into a container and
it's not really a good candidate to put
into a container sequel server by
definition it has a lot of state held
with it sequel servers tend to need you
know really heavy iOS and storage you
tend to build them with dedicated
storage for a lot of these reasons
containers just not the right place to
try and build that and especially the
fact that there's a lot of state with
these servers and the middle tier
application here this is actually you
know it's it's a stateless application
and the middle tier can actually scale
out so we could have dozens and middle
tears running in this application they
can run independently of one another so
it could be a really good you know
component to container ice in this case
here
it's tricky because it has a complex
component running at the core of it comm
decom and it's requiring on windows
authentication and that's going to make
things a little bit sort of sticky when
we go down the container stuff and we
look a little bit more of that later and
then on the web server side this is a
really excellent candidate for
containerization here in this case here
there are multiple websites on this web
server each of those could be split out
into separate containers and then
managed as individual web applications
there is no state generally in these web
applications all this state is held in
the database you know they can also
scale out so we could have multiple
nodes serving our users these ones here
they happen to be running in the SAP
location some classic ASP some deaqon
components ActiveX controls but those
actually can work in a container and
we're gonna have a look at that working
soon so when we're looking at this
somewhere you know deciding where to
start without containers we're gonna go
straight to the web server pup and then
you know maybe we can come back and have
a look at this middle tier as the next
sort of cab off the rank the web server
is this is the tier that's likely to
have the most changes to it as well if
our devs are going to be tweaking the
web portals and the in the web sites and
things that's where all the codes
getting it written this middle tier
component hasn't changed in 20 years
it's probably not going to change so you
know there's less benefits from being
able to roll out updates to that tier
there so another reason why you might
not jump straight into container izing
that one so ya get stuck in and
containerize this stuff so what are we
gonna do this is where most of my
windows friendly Edmonds sort of code
windows containers where's the gooey and
they're like harsh there's no gooey
now what so yeah windows containers are
headless windows server core is headless
windows nano server is headless so there
is no GUI you can't you know log on to
it you don't have you know all the
management tools sitting there
front of you you don't have an IDE
sitting in the air so it's a bit of a
paradigm shift for a lot of windows
admins and IOT ops people there is no go
so you've got to you know take a
different approach to your building and
developing your applications you can
actually get a container up and running
connect to it and do stuff inside of it
but you you would typically only do that
for debugging when you're developing
stuff when you're operating the server
you shouldn't really be going into each
thing at the command line and doing
stuff that's where you use monitoring
and diagnostics externally to you know
monitor things and if something breaks
in destroy the container and let a new
one come up to replace it but there are
tools to get in there and play around if
you need to when you're building and
doing for containers you're gonna really
you know reconnect with the command line
from ages ago
you're gonna learn to embrace things
like PowerShell and you know there's a
lot of commands and things that you'll
find really useful when you're you know
trying to get your application and get
it running inside of a container you
know with the modern dot need
application it's pretty much as easy as
deployed to contain a copy website run
it up and it works and it's it's pretty
straightforward for a legacy app
generally you've got a lot of other
stuff that you've got to deploy in there
you've got dll's you've got other
components you might have a you know an
old ODBC package that you've got to
install in the case of our middle tier
some msi from some vendor that doesn't
exist anymore for example actually this
one does but i've seen ones where where
vendors don't exist and you've just got
an emu site package that you've got to
somehow figure out what you want to do
to deploy it so a bunch of commands are
you gonna get used to when you're
working inside of windows containers and
giving and things are these this is
probably the IT ops people are going to
have to learn this and help the devs
you know get this stuff configured the
first time and but go away this supposed
to be ignoring sorry and yeah so the IT
ops are the people are the ones that
deployed the servers in the first place
they probably have the knowledge of how
to do this stuff they might not know how
to do it with a command
but no divs and ops will work together
to figure out how to get this stuff
going and then once it's been figured
out and scripted from there on and it's
a little bit of an easier ride so as
well as power show as I said MSI's and a
lot of msi installers generally people
would run up the msi and there would be
a whole lot of GUI screens you click
through and type boxes and it's headless
see you can't see a GUI when you try to
install something so you're gonna get
really comfortable really quickly with
you know using setup flags and quiet
install flags and especially log files
when you're trying to install stuff from
my size because most of the time an
image site is gonna fail on the first
couple of attempts and you're gonna be
pouring through your log files to figure
out what was missing what went wrong and
sometimes it's a dependency and
generally when you go to install an MSI
file the dependencies might not install
alongside of it on a command line
because they kind of spin up a second
process when you run setup.exe and it
does it and so now you have to figure
out they're gonna have to install dotnet
1.1 first and then go and run your msi
to get your application working but yeah
log files are gonna get really friendly
with an Emer size and command line
switches there so when we've you know
and we can do all of that inside of a
window serve headless node we don't
actually have to have a container at
stage we can spin up a Windows server
and the Nano server
well not for 32 but but I window civic
core and then figure out how to install
our applications and then we can take
the learning that we get from bet to
build out our windows containers so when
we're building up our windows containers
we're gonna use something called a
docker file and there's other ways to do
it as well but we're gonna start with
the docker file and a docker file just
like in the Linux world it's it's
basically a set of instructions as to
how to construct the resulting container
that you're going to use and it always
starts off where they're from so from
what base image and then you're going to
do a whole lot of commands to install
things
edie features register stuff in the
registry in this case here expose 80
means this container is going to X
Bo's port 84 a web app to communicate
across an entry point here which
basically says when this container
starts up and runs this is what's going
to run and when it stops my container
will stop we don't usually want it to
happen with a with a web server so we've
actually got a little tool which is nice
which is called service monitor which
will sit there and it'll run and we'll
watch the iis w3c service running and if
it detects it stops it will exit and in
the container except and you can start
it up again or create a new one and but
as long as it's running this will keep
the container up and running so
installing a whole lot of things and
then the last thing we tend to do is
copy our files and things for our web
sites into that and then any permissions
or acting and stuff that we want to do
building from that file so we've created
these commands we want to go and create
a container image from that this is
we're gonna use something called docker
built and we can do this on Windows 10
we can do it on Windows server etc if we
install the docker tools
we're gonna go docker build I always
like to tag mine with a name so that I
don't have to use random names to
connect to them when you want to run a
container image that you've built you're
going to have to map some Network ports
through so in this case here - Pia would
say map port 8081
- the port 80 inside the container
because you can't run multiple port 80 s
on one machine from from a networking
point of view - d we'll say run it in
the background then you can also once
that containers up and running maybe you
want to connect to it to have a look at
some logs mess around with it so then we
can use a docker exec command and the -
T I will say give me an interactive
session and then hold the TTY or hold
the text console and and and then what
we're gonna run command or PowerShell so
what that'll do is it'll open a session
into that container and we'll get our
command prompt or a PowerShell prompt
and then we can go and you know walk
through inside that container as though
we're just logged onto a server console
and then some other commands to show
what's running and docker and what
images we've got a more
so let's take a look and have a look at
an application or a site that I have as
part of this which is the way one day
okay
I'm actually working in the bun to show
on here even though I'm working with
Windows stuff I could just as easily do
this in a command dot exe window but I
actually come from a an old school of
running Linux machines and stuff and I
actually quite like the best shell for
automating stuff so I find myself
working in here quite a lot these days
but I am in a directory here and I have
in this directory I have my docker file
which is the instructions on how to
build this I have a folder called
packages which will hold any MSI
packages that I might need to install
I've got a folder called website which
is all the files for my website that are
in there and then I've got a couple of
scripts that I'm going to use which I
won't talk about just yet but if we have
a look first of all at the docker file
and I'm gonna open this up in Visual
Studio code and what we're gonna see
here is can you see that all right dude
I need to zoom in any further right okay
so I'm the first thing that we're doing
here is we're saying for this
application build it from the windows
server core container image version 1803
I could go just Windows server core and
it would just grab me the latest one but
it's a bit dangerous if you if you're
building containers you don't you don't
want to just use latest because as soon
as the new image is published you know
the next time you go to build you're
getting the new version and maybe you
don't want that next version just yet
you better to explicitly tell it which
versions and things that you want when
you're building your containers so the
first step there is saying I'm going to
use the base Windows server core image I
am building a web server here I could
have actually gone to the Microsoft
session I is image but in this case I
just wanted to use the the empty windows
one the next command here is basically
me saying I want
defaults to the PowerShell so any run
commands that I do inside my script will
actually use PowerShell as their default
language and the first command i'm doing
here is i'm doing a PowerShell install
windows feature web server normally i
wouldn't include management tools but I
was trying to debug some stuff on it on
an application so for my dear image I
threw them on as well but then the other
bits and pieces of power shelter just
add the features that you would normally
do on a Windows Server to install IAS to
install static content ASP so this is
classic ASP if you've got a closer
goes-p application and this one here
particularly important if you're running
32-bit stuff and the well 64 support
which is needed for the classic ASP so
Det will go through it'll install the
web server it will add those additional
web features then there's a couple of
other things I need to do if I'm doing
32 but sort of legacy apps one of them
is I've got to set a net pool to use
this enable 32 bit on Windows 64 flag
and if I don't do that then then my 32
bit stuffers is not going to run at all
and this one here I didn't technically
need it here but this is what I used to
tell it to run as a network service for
my is at pool and this practice would be
to not use the default at pool but to
actually create one and use it from
scratch but that that's just about
installing configuring iOS the next part
here again I wouldn't normally put that
into a production image but this was I
was trying to debug some stuff in this
image and attach some remote management
tools so I dropped it into to allow me
to connect to the web server remotely
this command here will basically take
all the files and my packages directory
which was this one here and what you can
see I've got some dll's in here some
ActiveX controls
and a certificate and an msi so if i
need to deploy these inside my thing and
install them inside in my container I'm
dropping them in a packages directory
copying that into the container and then
you know that to install this the ODBC I
have got this one here which is doing a
start MSI exec and pointing out that MSI
that I've just deployed inside the
container and scroll over a little bit
more you'll see /qn says do it silently
and then for this one here you also have
to come but crazy on my um my drink you
also have to accept some terms and
conditions when you install otherwise
it'll all fail miserably so so I'm doing
that there too so that that line there
is going to install the sequel MSI ODBC
my client into my server the next one
here I'm actually first of all I'm
sitting TLS on my network connection
because by default things don't use TLS
1.2 and a lot of websites are suddenly
starting to use this so in PowerShell
you're going to kind of force it that
way
and then I'm actually just going in
downloading a couple of files from
github and and in elsewhere into my
machine I could have also kept these in
the packages file and uploaded in that
way but I just wanted to pull them
straight from the web and the next bit
here is actually where I am registering
some of those those details those the
ActiveX dll's and things but I've
actually got that commented out right
now because I want to show that it's
broken and then I'll turn on and fire it
up and we'll see it working networking
so port 80 because my web server is
running on port 80 inside the container
by default the entry point that was
there monitored and monitor the web
service running and then the last step
there was basically all my web files on
my ASP files or my my website files
copying them into the container as well
so in order to to turn this into a
container this is where we've got to go
and then build this
this is the dockerfile and then we'll
use a docker build command to actually
go and build that and to save time I
have let's go I could have actually use
docker compose as well but I just like
scripting stuff so I've got a command
file here that I just run cuz I do it
quite a lot first thing I do is I stop
any existing containers using a dock
stop command I delete an existing
command container with a docker RM
command then I build the I build the the
docker file that I got the air and give
it a tag of web - booking so it's easy
to talk to whoops and then I'm going to
run that up in the background which is
the - D with the port mapping of 80 81
on my local machine to port 80 inside
the container the name of it's going to
be the web booking and the image that
I'm going to use is the word booking one
that I created just up here and then the
last one just basically fires up a
browser to take me straight to my web
page so when I run that what you'll see
when we zoom in a little bit it's
stopping it container now it'll stop it
fairly soon it'll remove the other one
and now it's starting to build
everything that was in that script and
the first bit ran really really fast and
you'll see one of the cool things as it
says here using cash so when it builds
an image it basically builds it and
saves it and builds it and saves it and
and if you change something in your
docker file and then you go and build it
again it doesn't go all the way to the
top and start over and if you change
something at the top of the file but
it'll s use the cache and then just add
on a layer after layer after layer to
get you a final output and and this is
the web page that's popped up and if I
hit the button here for lookup a job and
popping a ID and a thing then you'll see
I've got some some details from job that
comes up this is a container running on
my machine it's actually connecting via
an HTTP to a server that's up in the
crowd cloud that's running that middle
tier and that is up here and it's
fetching the details for this this job
here for a broken laptop service this
this website part here is kind of one
where people go in booking laptops to
get them serviced or phones or other
stuff it has a lookup job it also has a
book and a job so if you want to go and
book in your laptop to get some service
there's a there's a booking form in here
and this is a website that this is not
the actual live version of it the live
one looks a lot prettier and it changes
every time the company does their
branding so you can imagine that you
know companies quite often change their
branding a lot
the devs want to go and change these
websites so I want to tweak some things
on the formula put new pictures up and
being able to do the this website
separate from all the other websites
that are in there it's quite useful they
can go and change they spin it up and
contain a tester and then deploy it to
production without breaking all of their
other things so the other things that
I've got up in here the ActiveX test
page and this one here is throwing me a
big 500 error this is a page that if I
have a look at the code where it's my
code website this is just a basically
just a contrived example for ActiveX
because I didn't want to dig into the
other code but this one registers a an
ActiveX control and my web server the
server create object and that's the the
DLL that I'm calling and they're just
some for loops to just spit out some
math or maths I've been listening to see
if too much so that's failing right now
and the reason that's failing is because
yeah we haven't actually set up our
image properly and this is where you
know maybe being able to get inside this
container is going to be quite useful to
us so let me just zoom in a little bit
here
so if we wanted to get into this
container and and and see what's going
wrong then we can do a docker exec - ti4
hold the tty and do it interactively
we're booking is the name of my
container and I just want to run command
dot exe so now I'm inside that container
and if I do a derp this is the files
that are inside that container and if we
you know if I did a task list I'd see
the tasks that running in there so this
is running is and I know that there's a
log file than my eye net pub directory
so I'm just gonna go see any CD to own
it Pub CD to the logs and CDN to the w3
SVC one and then there is a log file
there that may not be full year I have
to wait a little bit I know it is okay
so there's the log files from iis and
what we'll see in here is there we go
so server create object failed so I know
that on my web code we try to hit this
page there was an error and it's giving
me the area here which is kind of nice I
was expecting that but now if I go back
to my docker file and I uncomment out
this one here that registers my dll's so
that's registering that image VB DLL
which is required because this stuff was
written in vb6 and it's registering my
DLL and with rich server 32 so it's it's
running that inside the container as it
builds so now what I can do is go back
exit out of the running container I'll
just do a quick docker PS so this is how
you can see all your running containers
and you can see my web booking one at
the top there is running or the name of
we're booking but now that I've changed
that file I'm just going to do a restart
and that's going to go and cause that to
rebuild and now what's going to happen
is because I changed this file at this
line here it's going to go to
this point in the build process it's
going to start from there and it's going
to rebuild everything below that so
we'll see that it's picked up the cache
and now it's going through and in this
case here you can see it's currently
executing the commands that are doing
the the read server 32 against those
dll's so hopefully that shouldn't take
very long and when that finishes the
website will come up and hopefully the
ActiveX stuff will work nicely again
take a little bit longer than that hope
oh here we go
ok the last steps come in the files
it's ping it up once once you've built
these images starting up a new one and
shutting them down only takes a few
seconds so it's it's actually quite good
so if I go and take a change of file and
the website and then rebuild and start
up a container it can it can be done in
like 30 seconds which is pretty good now
here's their website coming up and if I
hit the activists test page now you can
see I've got a nice little table with
some maths going on in there
and which means that it's basically
loaded up my DLL now it's built into the
image and now all that stuff's working
right so that's just some some basics
around building out a Windows container
with some docker and using a docker file
to spin that up right now that all this
is running on my machine
I've got docker installed on my machine
docker uses hyper-v on Windows 10 I
could be doing this on Windows here or
something else but it's running these
windows containers on my machine so the
the next thing that we might want to do
is actually get this container running
somewhere else and something that's
there's quite popular these days to do
that is kubernetes and how many people
here have used kubernetes cool
so Kuban is as what we call an
Orchestrator you can you build your
containers somewhere else then you
provide them to kubernetes
and you basically tell kubernetes how
you want your containers to run you tell
kubernetes what sort of networking you
want how many of your containers you
want to run how they want to be load
balanced you know with the deploy
whether they rely on other containers
how you want to spread them out across
your kubernetes clusters and you do it
with a little file you fire there and
then companies will bring up your
containers it'll run them if they die
it'll start them again if you tell them
you want in it'll create ten if you tell
them now you want 20 it'll go and add
another team to that and now you'll have
20 running so
communities is great it's a it's an
Orchestrator that does all these things
wonderfully it's got quite a lot of
features and it's not the only
Orchestrator but is basically become the
default Orchestrator I guess and the
most popular one and as I said earlier
it's got first-class support on
Microsoft Google I didn't edit this from
another talk I did but catalyst in New
Zealand as a as a open source focused
company that has their own cloud and
they they built a community service that
you can access as well so kubernetes is
becoming the default Orchestrator for a
lot of clouds for a lot of hosters in
the rest of it and the other thing
there's cool with kubernetes is open
source and so you know open source
software is really good these days you
get a lot of people making contributions
feeding stuff back in including
Microsoft including Google and then
there's also a good ecosystem of tools
that go with this things like using how
to do deployments instead of native
cubanía Gemmill files for example so you
can actually create right now a
kubernetes cluster in Azure as your Asia
whichever you like and you right now you
use the container service to do that or
you will use something called ACS engine
but you can if the container service you
can basically go through click a few
things feed in a service principal ID
and then have a kubernetes cluster with
Windows nodes that can run Windows
containers up and running and in a few
minutes probably about 15 I think it
takes generally but it's really nice so
this one here is one that you kind of
manage yourself in Asia and in Google
and an AWS there are kubernetes services
that are more pairs where they will
upgrade the control planes keep the
kubernetes versions sorted out for you
do all the patching on your nodes and
all that sort of stuff you can't yet run
Windows containers in those versions but
it is coming so for now you can spin one
up using a CS a CS engine
so when we've built that docker file
before with built-in image we're running
on a machine in order to get that into
kubernetes and running convenience has
to be able to access that image there
are a few different ways that you can do
this you could check your code in to you
know DevOps sorry into a source control
system which could then trigger off a
DevOps pipeline to maybe build your code
build the container push your container
through a process to a container
registry and then kubernetes could go
and grab the next version or you could
do that manually as well and in this
case here I have just pushed my images
from my machine up to a Azure container
registry I could have done it to a
docker registry as well one thing to be
careful of here and and why I'm not
doing it with this image today is that
the the Windows Server images are 5 gigs
and trying to push that up from from
here up to the cloud is a bit slow on
the Wi-Fi and yeah that's pretty common
so you can build your image you can push
the image that you've created on your
machine up to a registry or you can let
a pipeline take care of it once the
image is there then you can use the
default kubernetes Gemmell deployments
to basically describe what that
container is and how it needs to run and
and feed this into kubernetes and in the
in the yeah more file we've got things
like that the name of the container will
so if we're pulling it from a private
registry then we've got the the registry
address and maybe we pointed a
credential file so that we don't have
our credentials and plain text
everywhere and then we'll have a service
that's configured to say this container
needs port 80 redirected in from from
the public internet container I mean
from the yema one we'll use a tool
called qu control cube kettle KUB ECT or
if you like lots of ways of people call
it but this is something you can store
on your machine it's in there Azure
cloud shells by default but to get your
Yama file into a kubernetes cluster you
to cut all flesh cube color will apply
/f and the in pointed at your file and
it will deploy this file to Cuban
Eddie's and then kubernetes will pick it
up and find your container image turn it
on start it up and have it running in
macular networks and there's some other
commands that are useful there as well
and looking what's running and
describing them too so you can see if
something's breaking so let me jump over
to here so I have a an ICS cluster
that's up and running up and and Azure
and where is it gone let me just bring
it up okay let's take another well so
while I am there as I said we use that
little cube kernel to do things so I'm
just gonna do a get all and what this is
going to do is it's going to go and talk
to that server and then just tell me
everything that's running up on this
server right now and as you can see
we've got a couple of containers running
these ones here used well actually got
one container running and one of them is
zero zero zero is there but this is a
nano server so it was a little bit
smaller it was only a couple hundred
Meg's to seen up there but yeah it's up
and running and it's if I have a look at
this thing here this is the container
that's running and I go and talk to
describe this the end we'll see a little
bit more about what's going on in that
container or that specific instance that
container if I took the M if I go to
describe pod it will work
so this is telling me a little bit more
as you can see here it's got sir
look at here it's got port 80 exposed on
this container state running was telling
me a bit about the image ID and where it
came from and you know it's there's a
secret that was used to connect to the
volumes there and there was one that was
used to connect to the the container
registry service as well but it's that's
telling me that it's there if I also
have a look that's the the container
itself in my my ml file that I have and
if I just go and bring that up let's get
it over no no that one day sorry okay
yeah so the ML file which is the one
that describes this at the top of it
there this is the container that it's
running that port that we saw there's
also further down on there it tells that
that we've got a service that's attached
to this and this is where it's saying
that we want to basically map on our
kubernetes cluster we want to map port
80 and coming to that kubernetes cluster
to port 80 inside that container and at
this stage here there's no IP addresses
or anything like that there kubernetes
will take care of that for us and what
we can do is we can actually go and
fetch the information about that service
from the cluster as well and I just to
get all but what this will do is it'll
tell me what IP address the community's
cluster is assigned to this container
and I can see that it is 23 101 and now
if I go and jump up to my browser and
throw that in here
I can see that I got a container up
there it's just the default nano server
container running the iOS default
instance so that's up and running on
kubernetes right now that yam will file
that we've got here what I can do is I
can actually just go and run sorry I
don't want that UML file I want to go to
the NIT s1 because the other one takes
too long to load up so I want to go to
this file here and just the end of it
I'm just going to call it v2 so v2 is a
container that I actually edited before
basically change the default page and
give it some other stuff soon this yeah
more file here I'm just going to tell it
now I'm going to use this v2 image and
then in my command line I'm gonna go and
keep control apply - if and then my Nano
tml file whoops
misspelled right
yeah thanks and what that's going to do
is it's going to send this new version
of the configuration file up to
kubernetes community is going to look at
it it's going to understand as it says
there that the deployment has been
configured the service nothing changed
on but what that's going to do is it's
going to force kubernetes to basically
kill the container that's running and
then replace it with a new version of
that container and because this is only
a nano server it's only a couple hundred
mega shouldn't take very long and okay
the IP address hasn't changed so it came
up at some that was running and says
here for 20 seconds so it had already
come up at a time would stop talking and
if I go over here and refresh my webpage
you know now we see the the second
version of that container that the first
one was taken down the new version was
stood up which has the application
changes in it and all we had to do to do
the deployment of that was just tweak
one little character and a and a yema
deployment file so kubernetes and docker
swarm are ways that you can orchestrate
these containers so you can build these
windows containers you can have them
order build by pipeline pushed out to a
container registry and then your
Orchestrator can when it's told to pick
up the new version deploy it out to the
to the internet you can actually have
something like a service mesh running to
basically if you put up the new version
each container you could say I want to
see in there some users over to the old
version some users to the new version
and you know run an 80/20 split while
you're testing out the new version to
make sure it's all good and then perhaps
route everything to the second one but
it's a nice way that you can orchestrate
these things you can run multiple
versions and do testing in production
and all that sort of stuff as well so
that was just a real simple look at
kubernetes there are a few other talks
here and a few other talks at some of
the other indices which go much deeper
into kubernetes and how it all works and
our friend down the front here
was doing a great session that I saw
some of online the other day yeah for
kubernetes from Oslo so if you want to
learn more about communities or a
community go and look that communities
and and Oslo and sir what was the first
name again shade yes that's right with
my there's my powerpoint okay so it was
just a quick look at kubernetes there
are some things that as I mentioned
before that that middle tier that we had
that was running the Windows
authentication there are some things
with Windows Server and Windows
applications that as my colleagues is
the Herbie dragons authentication is I
mean it's never easy but in Windows
containers it's a lot harder than it has
been in the past Windows containers
you can't domain join a Windows
container so in the past we would run up
a Windows server you'd run up a is you
create an app pool and you'd see your
Apple identity to domain user then that
would flow through to talk to your
sequel server and all the magical
authentication would just flow and work
everywhere you can't do that in
containers but there are other ways that
we can do that there's there's a concept
called a group managed service account
which was born in a few years ago and
there is a way to basically have your
container run in the context of this
group managed service account and then
all the processes inside that container
will also run in that context as well
which is also a warning because if
you've got anything else that runs in
there that could potentially go out and
do things that it shouldn't do with
those credentials but yeah you can't
domain join a container but to use GS
MGM essays your container host needs to
be domain joint so the host that's
running your windows containers will
need to be joined to the domain
basically once you've done that and
configured the the identities then to
start up a container to tell it to use
this it's actually just a simple command
which I've got on on the next slide
the next one but basically you can do a
docker run with an extra command to
point out the credentials and then it'll
start up and it will use those
credentials one of the other things is
it's still a roadmap item for kubernetes
for communities on ACS convenience aks
so right now you can't really go and
join your kubernetes windows nodes to
the domain and have any authentication
so if you want to run authenticated
windows containers in production you're
probably going to have to go and look at
docker swarm right now to orchestrate
that or do your own orchestration with
your own posts but it is on the roadmap
so it will be coming so I'm enabling it
on the container host if you built a
Windows Server as a container host
basically you can just go in and use
some commandlets to add the the GSM GMs
a feature into your machine and then get
the account and install that account
into the container host and then once
you've done that you're there's a
library that you can rip down which will
basically go and create a JSON file
containing all the credentials that will
let you pass that to docker and then
pass through that authentication into
your container when you start it up and
when you start up your docker container
then there's an extra command and the
security option one here and this is
will pass through the credential spec
file which will have that dmsa ID and
password etc in it and the rest of it's
just that the normal commands that
you'll run once once they come when two
containers up and running you can exec
into the container and then just use an
email test current domain and it'll tell
you if your container is up and running
and it can see the parent domain and
they can do authentications to it this
will basically just tell it you know
tell you what it thinks as parent domain
is and give you an indication that it's
actually working there is a really good
walkthrough in to end up and github if
if you want to grab it from there and I
will actually make these slides
available somehow afterwards as well so
you can grab a copy of them as well and
maybe just email me or tweet me if you
a copy and I'll seen them there yeah so
you can start a container with these
credentials and then everything inside
that container will run using these
credentials so if I is is running in
there now the IAS process will be
running as your group MSA account and
then a Phet account has been given
permissions to read tables and sequel
for example now your web server can then
just go and read tables and sequel so
then you can get this kind of
application that maybe requires trusted
connections through to the sequel server
because not all legacy apps support non
trusted connections they don't support
standard sequel authentication so there
are ways to get that working as well so
that I was going to jump into that I
didn't don't really have time to dig too
deep into the end to the GMs a-working
but it all it really does and the demo
has shows you some rows coming out of a
sequel server database so it's not that
exciting
my wrist is buzzing some of is your
massage so what's coming up there is
there's a blog post out there that talks
about being able to run Linux containers
and windows containers on the same
machine without having to run virtual
machines to run your Linux containers in
the docker
client have you enable the experimental
features you can actually do that
already
so there's a blog post up there that you
can hunt out and find quite easily and
then also Windows Server 2019 which is
due out in the second half of this year
I'm not sure if there's any big events
happening soon but maybe there is but
you can see a couple of big investments
that they have in Windows Server 2019
there are around containers the first
one there is improved support especially
around you know the orchestrators like
kubernetes and so that they can
basically connect storage control your
compute and and and basically that you
control those windows containers on a
kubernetes cluster just like you can do
that with Linux containers right now
additional support to make it work on
RedHat OpenShift
which also is a another Orchestrator
which a lot of people using so you know
if you're running rich red hair
openshift now you'll be able to or soon
you'll be able to throw some windows
nodes into the mix around windows
containers on windows nodes Linux
containers on Windows Linux nodes and
you know have mixed deployments hybrid
deployments and are also optimizing you
know the images for core and Nano
further getting them smaller because
small is always better and containers
and then there's more improved Linux
support in general as well and so that
Linux containers on windows that we saw
before a lot more support going into
that and then Windows is also starting
to roll out some tools by default that
you'd normally find on on Linux things
like you know OpenSSH cool tar so when
you're doing mixed work with Linux and
Windows you'd kind of start to rely on
these tools and it's a pain when they're
not there so they're starting to roll
those into Windows by default as well
Nix tips if you're a man if you're
interested in in trying out some you
know windows containers stuff yourself
maybe try and move some applications
around one of my colleagues Paul Bauer
is he built a workshop for the
Australian container camp and also the
UK container camp which is a couple of
weeks ago but there is a link to Paul
Bowers github repo up there inside that
repo is a another dick and PDF and then
a few demos that that you can walk
through and in some labs that you can
follow to go and build out windows
containers and get them up and running
and get apps working inside of them if
you're new to containers or kubernetes
my organization also runs these things
called open hacks and we actually had a
container open heck here in Sydney a few
weeks ago there is one coming up in
Auckland and November and I know there's
a couple in the US and Europe coming up
as well but these are three-day events
where you come in you work as a team to
work through a set of challenges which
basically start off with getting docker
running on your machine and end up with
doing orchestrating of workloads and
committees across clouds with routing
and redundancy and monitoring and all
that sort of stuff not everybody that
will come
these will get from from zero to the end
depending on their level of experience
and I find that the people that have
some experience breeze through you know
the first couple exercises and then get
on to stuff like learning how to do
monitoring learning how to do you know
traffic routing and fail overs and
things like that so they're good event
if you if you're brand new or if you're
a little way in to come in and scale up
really fast work with a team of people
to get further betting I keep an eye out
for open hacks and come to Oakland if
you want to as well so that was that was
me thanks for listening and is there any
time for questions or are we all out no
we're all out sorry come and see me
afterwards and I'm around and thanks for
coming along